welcome back at 6 23. are you looking
for love I mean there is no shortage of
sites and groups and things to join but
you know to find that deeper connection
so joining me now Amy lettingham she is
a Master Certified relationship coach
and Amy you have some dating tips three
yes for lasting love and and that I
think ultimately is what we all want is
a partner for Life absolutely let's dive
in well okay first things first follow
the 90-day rule okay yeah so many of us
get caught up with chemistry and
excitement and we forget that we're
meeting the representative they're on
their best behavior yes right so we want
to slow down and learn what's beneath
the tip of the iceberg like what's their
values what's you know what their
beliefs are who's what is their
character right I mean companies vet
people for 90 days before they hire them
we need to apply that before we commit
to someone boy that's a really good
point and think a lot of companies even
hiring you still have that window after
you're hired so okay being on your best
behavior yeah we all put on that face so
that's great advice at least three
months okay now tell me about you know
an example of something that might be
non-negotiable for for folks you know
when it comes to non-negotiables people
need to make a list it's really
important because and it's not the
obvious one I want somebody that's
financially stable or I want someone the
no-brainers yeah no it's the unconscious
ones the ones that we get into a
relationship where it breaks our
relationship up like somebody that's
emotionally unavailable okay so we need
to make a list and say okay I'm looking
for someone emotionally available this
time and what does that look like for me
specifically and that's going to help
you avoid a lot of the dead end
relationships do you find a lot too with
those non-negotiables there might be
some family or you know certain I want
kids or I want a dog kind of things as
well absolutely and it's okay to that
all those things up front you know we
don't want to wait until we're six
months down the line already invested to
do this vetting we need to do it early
on that's when that's when the
Heartbreak happens so why is being the
Chooser so important when you're looking
for love yes that's my be the Chooser
not the chosen we get so excited and I
was like I want this person to choose me
yes oh I got picked yeah okay no no okay
we don't want to do that we want to be
the Chooser we want to ask ourselves
wait a minute do I really like this
person after all the chemistry and the
hormones
the butterflies dissipate you're left
with the person and your relationship so
be the Chooser and ask do I choose this
person even though they choose me that
is a great piece of advice Amy how can
folks find you if they're looking for
love and need a little assistance
because we know it's hard here in Las
Vegas thank you so much for asking
amythedating coach.com and it's spelled
Amie the dating coach.com great we're
going to put that information on our
website too for those of you who are
looking for love Amy is the lady who
might be able to help you do it thank
you again for being here on the show
great tips remember 90 days more good
days after the break